e
good morning everyone W that was loud um
I'd like to call this meeting to order
um we are the special committee on covid
response efficacy and I would like to
ask a representative leus to lead us in
I pledge aliance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all I just like to remind everybody that
this bipartisan committee is tasked with
investigating and evaluating the state's
response to the covid-19 pandemic the
committee will function in a
science-based fact finding review
specifically acquiring comprehensive
accurate data and all related
information pertaining th to areas of
particular Focus will include the
administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of emergeny use
authorization vaccine efforts a report
will be issued outlining the committee's
findings and the impact on New Hampshire
I'd also like to remind everyone that
um people uh may have differing in
opinions and let's be courteous to each
other and treat everyone with respect
and I would like to call Alicia Houston
okay thank
you um I apologize I wrote everything
down on my all right just state your
name and where you're from for the
record please so good morning
Representatives my name is Alicia
Houston and I am from nashaa New
Hampshire I want to start by thanking
you for your time today to speak
regarding the covid response in my city
of nasua New Hampshire I will be frank
the handling of covid in the city of
nasua was a thing of nightmares for many
adults parents and most importantly for
our
children from March of 2020 to February
of 2021 the ntional school district
refused to reopen at a full-time
capacity for in-person learning it
wasn't until Governor sununu issued an
emergency order for a return to school
that forced the hand of the district to
reopen for its students that should not
have been the case you see from March of
2020 to February of 2021 Nashville Board
of Education comprised at the time of
mostly Democratic elected individuals
there were thousands of children who
went without the opportunity to learn
freely in any classroom environment
including remotely the Board of
Education in my city never received
thousands of taxpayer funded Chromebooks
which left children without the ability
to learn additionally children did not
have accessibility to internet in some
lowincome areas they essentially
declined to make adjustments to afford
all NASA children a fair opportunity at
their right to free public free
appropriate public education they simply
didn't
care now I'm not simply I'm not simply
saying this out of spite I am saying
this from a place of critical thought
and after years of reflection on how
this could have been more appropriately
handled they could have done better they
could have treated those of us who spoke
out in opposition better they could have
been better and overall chose not to do
so along with many other state
representatives through throughout New
Hampshire in other cities and towns the
city of NASA imposed a Citywide mask
mandate for over a year regardless of
data provided to at the time mayor
appointed director of Public Health
Bobby Bagley at many points throughout
the pandemic questions were asked
surrounding the validity of the metrics
being used to Monitor and determine
reopening plans and mandates all of
those questions went unanswered and when
provided direct responses from Cheryl
Cheryl neelsen and Elizabeth Maynard at
the Department of Health and Human
Services specifically laboratory
services which handled the results of
all New Hampshire testing Miss baggley
remained steadfast in her directive of
keeping nashaa closed and masked New
Hampshire never calculated the overall
CT viral load value when determining the
actual transmissibility of covid-19 ever
I say this as someone who probed the
questions alongside hundreds of others
and yet even with proof of inflated and
inaccurate numbers many felt as though
we were screaming from the rooftops and
no one was listening at this time
history and virology were thrown out the
window in addition to deliberately
ignoring specific email responses to
questions asked at the state level with
confirmation that the data that was
being used was not accurate and that we
were not actually able to appropriately
calculate for transmissibility rates
without the CT VI without the CT viral
load values the ways in which those who
spoke out were treated was abhorent we
can do better
as someone who was never involved in
politics prior to covid-19 my only
purpose of becoming involved was to
benefit the children of nasua my
involvement and speaking out ultimately
resulted in elected officials including
state representatives labeling myself
and others as white supremacist
neo-nazis who belonged to what they
referred as teacher sacrificing Cults
simply because we wanted children to
have access to their classrooms again in
person it was one of the worst
experiences of my entire entire life
myself and my best friend received death
threats we were cyber stocked we were
doxed by state representatives teachers
targeted us and our children and so much
more all because we spoke up because and
advocated for a return to inperson
learning children went without learning
which resulted in later confirmed
learning loss the isolation of denial of
access to social settings for children
resulted in later confirmed mental
health challenges the implementation of
mandatory vaccines for employment
resulted in thousands of lost jobs for
people throughout the state regardless
of information that was provided to
Representatives elected officials and
appointed leaders in our communities we
were simply ignored and later realized
and confirmed our data points and
research but never even bothered to
acknowledge any wrongdoings or apologize
to New Hampshire residents for
mishandling any outcomes or committed
denial of fact of facts as I sit here
before you today after taking time to
reflect on the pandemic responses and
the handling of covid-19 I again say we
could have done better we should have
done better many ask for honesty
transparency accurate statistics and
overall human decency we were mostly met
with labels threats and so much more I
implore this committee to also reflect
on the outcomes of handling of the
pandemic and to do better in the future
thank you for your time I yield to any
questions
please thank you madam chair and thank
you for the testimony in
hindsight what would you recommend could
be done differently because when we get
into something like this there are
differences of opinion and how do we
resolve that difference of opinion and
still respect each other's rights so you
have any
solutions I would I would say that
reviewing the facts um and being
open-minded um there was a lot of
closed-mindedness again reflecting back
on how we could have done things
differently it was a very emotional time
for a lot of us um but to give an
example we were given specific data and
facts and it would have been better
suited for people to read the data and
facts as elected officials taking out
the political biases um and looking at
it at face value because the thing is we
didn't focus on the accurate numbers and
going forward in the future if you look
at the accurate numbers and the
statistics and what needs to be
calculated in a situation like that um
specifically CT values um viral load uh
if those things are not being calculated
and we're basing our decisions on
closing or reopening or mandates um
things along those lines if you don't
calculate in the things that matter in
order to determine the transmissibility
rate and we ignore those facts
regardless of differing opinions numbers
don't
lie
followup that's insightful so thank you
do you think this is something that
should be done by the state or done by
local municipalities because I'm a
strong believer in local control and not
having the state trumpet over
municipality's rights so in hindsight
again is this something that really
should be done broadly at the state
level and take away that autonomy of the
municipality or should it reside at in
the municipality and municipality have
the resources to actually do what you're
recommending so that that's a difficult
question for me to answer um I although
I agree with local control I think that
there's there's a magnitude that goes
along with that because every area is
different and every area needs something
different um I think that there could
have been a standard set um by the state
that the cities should have followed um
the state of New Hampshire specifically
the Department of Health and Human
Services um I have emails I would be
more than happy to send anybody the
email confirmation that needs it um I
have to go back into the archives it's
from 2021 so um but setting a standard
at the state level of how the tests are
going to be handled and what statistics
need to be there in order to determine
whether or not we reopen or we close
schools or mandate masking um like I
said I have the email we ask
specifically what needs to be calculated
in order to determine transmissibility
and if that had been done at the state
level for cities like my myself um again
it was a very emotional time um I think
although local control matters a lot to
me our local control didn't listen to us
regardless of the facts that we
presented forward from the state of New
Hampshire um so yes I would say local
control matters um but at the state
level we really needed a benchmark um
things like the reopening Mandate of
schools that um Governor senu had the
executive order those things could have
happened sooner on so that the kids
didn't suffer all that period of
time thank
beler thank you madam chair and thank
you for your testimony this morning uh
to follow up uh a little further with
the idea of the local control question I
guess I I would ask as far as what you
think the extent of that should be given
for instance that um the New Hampshire
Department of Justice has a civil rights
Division and they regularly will file
civil rights charges against people all
over the state for various violations or
or alleged violations um at the state
level do you feel like your civil rights
were respected during this process so
that is an excellent question um I was
actually one of the ones um that pointed
people into the direction of the Civil
Rights um spe specifically the
disability rights Center um to file uh
requests for comprehensive services for
students that were without in-person
learning and at the detriment of their
children did I specifically have my
civil rights violated um in a lot of
ways sure um you know mandating
different types of things wearing a mask
um in order to go to the grocery store
because of a mask mandate um not being
able to move about freely um to exercise
My First Amendment right those types of
things were absolutely restricted um I
would like to keep it specific right now
to the children um there were a lot of
civil rights that were violated um to
give you an example on a personal level
um I had a child who had a disability I
had a letter from his pediatrician
that it was a mask exemption letter it
was provided to the Nashville School
District my child was chased down
hallways he was called the wrong last
name because I am who I am um and I
spoke up he was denied the ability he
was left outside to sit outside by
himself at 16 years old um could I
pursue different Avenues to seek legal
action yes do I have the ability to
afford doing that as a single parent in
New Hampshire absolutely not um there
were a lot of civil rights that were
violated um comprehensive services in my
city were automatically denied there was
a blanket letter that was sent out for
any special education student um I again
I I'm more than happy to share any of
this I'm not just talking out of the
seat of my pants these are things that
we experienced in real time um but yes
to answer your question in a long-winded
way um there were civil rights that were
violated
absolutely represent
Merchant thank you madam chair and also
thank you for taking the question during
the testimony what I heard was that
there was an issue with Chromebooks and
not having availability to them which
brings up another issue do you believe
would you speak to the fact that a lot
of Educational Funding is done locally
and not by the state should the state be
responsible providing sort of a platform
of technology to be sure we have a Level
Playing Field we don't have a technology
Gap so students have the ability to use
that technology when they need to should
it be a state responsibility should it
be something by local
municipalities so again another really
great question the problem with that is
um bringing it back to local control it
would be really difficult for the state
to mandate something along those lines
um specific to you need to have X Y and
Z in order to have these children um
doing these things because the reality
is funding is going to look different no
matter depending on where you are
Lichfield is going to look different
than Hudson Hudson's going to look
different than nasua um could we have in
the future if this were to happen um
have an oversight to ensure that
children have their fundamental right to
fape free appropriate public education I
think that that would be something that
maybe a committee of some kind could be
developed not necessarily to demand
certain actions be taken with taxpayer
funds but to ensure that um in an
example of the Esser funds they needed
to provide documentation to the
Department of Education on how those
funds were spent um maybe doing some
kind of audit to ensure that those funds
were spent appropriately to benefit the
children um I know that in nashaa uh a
lot of the funding was used to um
provide teacher payment which is
fantastic teachers are wonderful we need
them obviously um but there were
thousands and thousands of children that
went out went without Chromebooks um
that were purchased but were never
received so I think that some kind of
oversight might be helpful as a
directive not as a demand but kind of
like a liaison to assist communities uh
to ensure that they're doing what's best
children represent
leus thank you for coming in um can you
give more specific harms that were done
during that time specifics of various
kids or your own child that
um particularly any long-term harms or
Etc so um my children are going to be so
bummed out that I'm talking about them
they're so tired of it but um my my
oldest son was the one with a mask
exemption um so a perfect example would
be um he would go to school to learn he
had a mask exemption I provided that
documentation there were no reasonable
accommodations that were made um there
are so many laws that that that were
violated through that um but the
long-term lasting effects um he doesn't
want to speak up anymore the idea of
standing up for something is terrifying
to him the idea of me standing up
sitting not standing but sitting here in
front of you today um makes my hands
clammy it makes me nervous um I'm
worried that there will be a Target
painted on my back again um that someone
somewhere because of differences of
opinions um will will get the bright
idea of sharing my address or my phone
number with someone um that I will have
to look over my shoulder um to make sure
that the death threats that I received
back then um were not followed through
on um so there are long-term effects uh
our youngest son is very very shy uh he
missed out on he was during covid he was
in the fifth grade uh at the tail end of
fifth grade when everything happened uh
he didn't return back to school again
for almost a year he lost a year he's a
very shy kid um he has a really hard
time making friends um they lost a lot
of that social interaction uh I have
friends uh who have children that were
younger going into kindergarten um and
from firsthand experiences they have
delayed learning we have uh a 63%
proficiency rate um in I believe it's
math uh there's like a 42% proficiency
rate for nasua and and again I'm
spitballing I don't have the numbers
directly in front of me um for reading
and those types of things are going
going to take years to redo there were
no comprehensive services for the
special education students um so those
long-term effects are going to be long
lasting things you know um occupational
therapy was missed you can't do speech
therapy through uh with a child who is a
visual learner through a computer um if
you had a lower income and you didn't
have access to a Chromebook you didn't
have access to an education um so
speaking specifically to my family um my
children were dramatically impacted I
was dramatically impacted um I even you
know things like looking for a job there
are things out there that were put out
into the world that were not true
because of differences of opinions
because I spoke up uh during a time when
we needed the facts and we needed the
logic and I was trying to help and Aid
uh with probing questions and emails
from you know heads of departments that
proved that we weren't accurately
reflecting the numbers it's terrifying
it's scary to sit up here today and in
front of all of you and whoever's
watching um but those those things are
going to last a lifetime so I hope that
that answered your
question thank you representative eel
thank you I'm sorry those things
happened and um I even in the best of
circumstances it can be hard to sit here
and after what you uh went through I you
know I'm
sympathetic um so you know we're not
experts at this and so I'm just I was
just going through the timeline here of
emergency orders uh when vaccines first
became available and I'm just wondering
so it says here um in February of 2021
cunu issued an emergency order mandating
schools offer in-person instructions to
all students at least two days a week
starting March 8th 2021 I was just
curious as far as NASA was concerned
what Nashua did and were you wanting
them to open before that or hoping they
would open before that or did they not
comply with the order I was just trying
to think of how all that played out so I
sat in my car today for like an hour
trying to look back um you know it's
kind of like that whole I hate using
PTSD but you get PTSD when you we feel
it just when you go back into the
archives and you're like wait I can't
remember the date and I need to remember
the date so um we did not return to
impers learning until the executive
order and I don't remember exactly what
date it was um it was a 3:00 p.m. uh
hearing and uh Governor cunu required
that all schools return to full-time
in-person learning by April of of
2021 um it wasn't until that that
emergency order was made that the
children returned back to school at a
full-time capacity um even special
education students that should have had
the opportunity to go back to school um
I believe there was an additional
executive order at some or emergency
order at some point I can't remember
which one it was the numbers all come
together um but the special education
students were afforded the opportunity
to go back sooner than that um and again
nasua refused to reopen at the directive
of our director of Public Health Bobby
baggley and the um metrics that she set
forward until Governor sonunu required
that they return to full-time by April
of 2021 because I was I mean we can look
more at this but I was trying to figure
out when um the limitations on public
Gatherings were you know uh repealed and
how that worked into the options for
schools to get back into session if they
wanted to I do see that the vaccines
weren't really available until like
February of 2021 I talk about PTSD I'm
reading this huge
no um so the other thing I wanted to ask
you is do you have and I realized you're
not an expert anymore than we are but do
you have a sense of how many other
schools other than nashaa actually
reopened and was was nashaa sort of a
lagard nashille is one of the last
school districts to open full-time um
all of the other school districts um I
I'm sure that other representatives in
in different areas um could speak to
when they reopened NASA was forced to
reopen if the governor had not made that
order I will answer bluntly nashaa was
not reopening the schools until someone
made them reopen the schools so just one
more so we um just obtained the after
action report that homeland security has
been working on for several months
through a consultant and um I haven't
read it all but it looks like yeah maybe
you have uh but apparently there there's
a task force and there
they're looking into all of these things
um not just schools but in general so
you might want to take a look at that uh
after Action Report um be interesting
from your perspective to see what you
think as far as the schools but I'm
hopeful that by doing this work um we're
going to get some help in figuring all
this out for the
future I I I would love a copy of that
I'm sure um representative leas would
send me that over if possible or I can
research it um you know one of the
things that we hadn't talked about that
that I'll add on to your request and how
we could handle things differently a lot
of jobs were lost um without a lot of
data and facts and and statistics and
and when you talk about the vaccines
because you had mentioned the vaccines
um some of the things that as parents
who had been doing the research um
things like the National Institute of
Health quietly researching the impacts
of this this um this vaccination uh
specifically I believe it's Johnson and
Johnson and you can research it and and
look into it um and it's impact and
effects on uh the menstrual cycles of
females um that has now since expanded
uh so I would definitely encourage you
to look into that study uh additionally
uh the studies regarding
myocarditis um and I had taken my son to
a uh physical and on the back of the
handout that they hand you after years
of saying the new the National Institute
of Health is is studying whether or not
there are you know potential
interactions or links to myocarditis it
lists it right on the back um so it was
an incredibly difficult time for all of
us um there's a lot of research that we
have now that we didn't have back then
um my big thing would be focusing on how
this impacts the children in the future
um you know social interactions mental
health uh there was a lot of mental
health crises during that period of time
um there was a lot of uh lost learning a
lot of things that are going to take
years and years to undo if we can ever
undo them or repair them um so that
would be something that I would implore
this committee to do is to continue
doing the research read um that uh the
report from the task force um through
the Department of Homeland Security um
and just keep yourselves educated at the
same time as keeping yourself
open-minded um we didn't need to make
this political it didn't need to be a
right versus left it needed to be a how
do we help the kids and how do we make
sure that these kids have the things
that they need in order to continue
learning to grow um because they were
inhibited with a lot of things uh and
education represent
Bel thank you madam chair and just to uh
just to help clarify timeline and
whatnot I've just sent an email to the
committee to reading to the record a New
Hampshire Public Radio article from
November 9th of
20120 um in which it describes that many
districts in New Hampshire are open at
least for now with the hybrid are fully
inperson model but Nashua School disc
REM school districts have remained
closed since March so November and I
believe the testimony is that they
didn't open up until March or April of
21 so it looks like they would have been
definitely one of the later um districts
to reopen I believe that when I was
looking through um in in the research um
I believe it might have been closer to
February um but it definitely was after
uh and and the only reason why I'm
saying this is because I I received a
phone call from the governor's office
saying you you girls won the schools
have to reopen um because we essentially
um sent every single email uh courtesy
copying uh the governor and then many
many many other Representatives
um so March might be a stretch um but I
do believe it was in February at some
that well I would like to thank you for
being here and um coming out and telling
your story I do have a couple of
questions for you and I'm not sure if
you can answer them or not but school
districts were giving an awful lot of
arpa funds
um to
help with a lot of the mitigation and to
help
students um I think I heard and you
please correct me if I'm wrong is that
nashor purchased Chromebooks but they
did not distribute them is that a
correct statement on my part so nashaa
purchased I can't remember the exact
number um my I'm trying to go back and
and remember but there was so much um
Nasha purchased Chromebooks uh from a
company and those Chrome books were not
received Additionally the Chromebooks
that were distributed were never there
was no enforce of actions to obtain them
uh families at the end of
2021 um were sent a letter uh that said
hey you still have a Chromebook turn it
in or else uh and and those Chromebooks
a lot of them many many of them I don't
know the exact number I can find it if I
really wanted to um but a lot of those
Chromebooks were never returned so those
Chromebooks were not received for the
district so okay so they ordered them
but they were never sent them do you
know if they were paid for um I would
have to look into um I would have to
look into the how the S Sesser money was
spent um I do have a couple of board of
education members that I can reach out
to I do believe that they were received
much later on um at a time when we
really didn't need them because the kids
were already back to school at that
point um but I do know that I believe
that they were paid for and received at
a later time but they were not received
in in a timely manner when the kids were
in remote learning when it was essential
for them to to have access to those okay
thank you for that do you know um
because we are talking about the
children and we're talking about the
health and safety of everybody in the
schools do you know if any of the money
was spent on air filtration systems to
try and mitigate um the viruses in the
classroom so that that people could
return sooner rather than later so they
did use uh some of the funds to update
the HVAC systems I do know um that some
of that funding was utilized for that
and in several of the schools there were
some schools that were up to date that
had been previously um updated prior to
covid uh but I do know that some of the
HVAC systems were
um were updated okay um I guess some um
HVAC system is being updated is good but
did they I guess the question is is did
they put air filtration s
uh in those systems uh which would help
uh right so ju that's just a question
that I have um and I'm sure you can't
answer that so yeah I'm I'm not sure um
I know that if the HVAC system was
installed I would I would hope that
someone somewhere with the SR funds
would have said we need to add a
filtration system but I'm not I can't
confirm it I mean they are you can look
at what was and was not spent uh through
the department of uh education in New
Hampshire on uh where the covid money
was spent through the documents that
they were required to submit prior to
the release of the
funding um I know uh listen in listening
to your testimony and hearing uh that
you were threatened
I hear I seem to hear that more and
more um from
people that wanted to get back to school
or that were outspoken
um we're in a very volatile uh political
environment
unfortunately
um and do you think that the government
whether it be at the state or the
federal level helped in Institute fear
that trickled down so that that is
really What affected people
um doing those things to you and do you
think because I don't know we can't stop
people
from their opinions we all have
different opinions we're unique we all
have different
biases um based on our
situations but where do you think that
originated if you had to
if you thought about it um why it became
so prevalent and for you personally
because you were one of those outspoken
parents um I think that there was a
certain level of uh of fear-based
information uh it depends on where you
look it depends on where you're getting
your your facts and and your information
um there's still fear that goes along
with it even with the research and the
the evidence that we have that supports
a lot of the claims that people like
myself were making um back then I think
that there was um there was a political
divide uh and unfortunately not many
people in that point in time uh could
walk in what my friends and I and and
people that I spoke with that are
like-minded not a lot of people could
walk in a gray area it was very much a
right versus left um and a lot of people
that you know uh were unfortunately I I
I'll speak Frank um a lot of the people
that were in the Democratic party did
have a very fear-based
response um based on what they were
being told um we were told that this is
one of the deadliest viruses ever um I
don't remember what the end uh statistic
was but a virus with a 99 something per
survival rate um that that is a very
fear-driven
narrative um thinking about how the
numbers and the information was reported
added to additional fear um to give you
an example you could have gotten bit by
an alligator and go to the hospital um
for an alligator bite obviously not in
New Hampshire but um to go to the
hospital with an alligator bite and
being treated for an alligator bite but
if you tested positive for covid and you
died from the alligator bite it has been
proven that sometimes those deaths
counted as a covid related death so
there was a level of fear um and there
was a level of refusal to acknowledge
facts and logic um and and critical
thinking unfortunately and that happened
on the right and the left um things that
could have been done uh at the state
level uh for you know for from a
representative
perspective um one of the big pieces I'm
going to say it and you all might cringe
um the parental Bill of Rights that was
brought forward in the last legislative
session that was uh shut down at its
core when it was initially introduced um
a lot of it was specific to um obviously
curriculum and things along those lines
but forced mandated vaccinations um that
was that was a big thing for a lot of
people um so at a legislative level
making sure that the parents feel
confident in sending their child to
school we had a child in nasua that was
vaccinated for the flu without a consent
form things like that um but it was very
fear-driven it came from the top and it
made its way all the way to the bottom
and if you spoke uh in opposition to the
mandates or to wanting to reopen the
schools um there were labels thrown out
and it it was it was scary for a lot of
us um other things that legislation
might have been able to do at the state
level um I don't know if you guys are
aware and I might be misspeaking and if
I am someone somewhere is going to
correct me absolutely I guarantee it um
you there are no criminal um there are
no criminal consequences throughout the
state of New Hampshire for cyber
stalking or doxing a uh resident or a
citizen that only applies through I
believe State uh law and again if I'm
wrong um please correct me send me an
email um I'm happy to to correct myself
um there is no such thing as a
cyberstalking or doxing law that
prevents people from doxing residents it
does apply to elected officials but it
doesn't apply to Citizens so someone
like myself who speaks out um whose
address is shared um who you know uh is
is cyber stalked by a number of people
elected individuals cyberstalking me you
try to seek recourse for that to correct
those behaviors so that it stops
happening and people learn their lesson
right as an accountable accountability
don't do things or there are
consequences um there were no
consequences for a lot of the people
that committed these horrible horrible
things against people like myself who
spoke
out well I thank you for your candid
honesty um in your opinions here today
and what you've experienced is just
horrific um I think that like you said
everyone needs to be
open-minded and understand where other
people are coming
from um because we all come from
different places and have different
opinions but we really need to learn to
listen to each other and it's not an US
versus them mentality
and I think kindness can go a long way
treating everyone with respect no matter
where their opinion comes from um I
think is something that needs to be
restored um here and and we can start
hearing this and you know it really
needs to you know happen um in my
personal opinion
obviously um but I do really appreciate
you coming in and telling your story and
I am sorry that your children and then
all the other children um have these
experiences and that have mental health
issues now because of it and are behind
in educa in their education so um I'm
very sympathetic to that uh does anyone
else have any other questions no thank
you so much again for being here and if
you could email us uh your testimony
that would be wonderful uh that way we
can H we'll have your email address and
if uh anyone has any of the documents
that she mentioned would like those
emailed we can get those requested um
and we can communicate with you via that
so that absolutely I I and again I
appreciate you all taking uh some time
to listen to me um and I know that I
mentioned some of the things that um
that I had access to I'm happy to send
uh any information I will get my
testimony over to you if you want to see
any of the documentation I'm happy to
send that I'm an open book but I
appreciate your time
much um this isn't a I just uh want to
submit this after action report for our
record so we can get it up on our site
so I'll get it to our committee
assistant perfect okay and you do know
the other report is on our site also y
okay um I believe uh representative is
anyone else in the audience wishing to
speak
no um representative leus uh do you want
to please has some information she would
like to share and she wants to sit up
please state your name and where you're
from for the record
please representative Alicia leus
Hillsboro 38 move the mic closer to you
please there you
go and I appreciate you letting me talk
I um am leaving on Monday for Europe for
seven weeks so I will not be here for
the rest of this committee unfortunately
because I've enjoyed working yes do you
need someone to handle a
[Laughter]
luggage if you can fit in it I'll take
you um so I had things that I had wanted
to say since I won't be around to say
them
later um and if you'll pardon me I did
write it
because frantically trying to get
everything taken care of before leaving
I have not been getting enough sleep and
when I don't sleep I lose my
words
um so what is the scientific method now
my dad was a physicist my dad had over
200 um patents to his name he and his
friend Freddy Friedrich developed the
quartz hogen lamp which you all I
presume are familiar with um he
developed the lights that are currently
lighting the Statue of Liberty he did a
lot of very interesting things and he
drilled into us as kids logical thinking
and the scientific method and what he
explained to us was when you have an
idea Theory
hypothesis you want to check it
out but and it'd be really nice to prove
that it's true but that's next to
impossible to do so what you do instead
false and if you prove that it's false
then you look at it and you take your
new information and you revamp your
theory and you go from there and you
keep working on it until you end up with
the theory that you can't prove is
false and why do you want to do that
well reality has a way of jumping up and
hitting you in the
face so if you're following and acting
on a theory that's false you're lamp can
fail your Bridge can fall your patience
can die right so you don't want to be
acting on false information or false
ideas um and to prove it false all you
need is one counter example and then so
you know okay it doesn't mean throw out
the whole thing it means that you got
part of it wrong so you you go again you
look at it you put your new information
in and you keep working on it and when
you get to the point where you can't
come up with any other
rigorous um experiment and by rigorous
one thing you need to worry about is
only one variable at a time right if you
have multiple variables how do you know
what the answer is one variable at a
time he taught us to look very carefully
and see how else might this be um what
else might be causing this what am I
overlooking Etc this is The Way We Were
brought up as kids I went on to physics
and Mathematics my brothers did similar
such
things
um if you're in a company you open that
up to other people in the
company and you know you work together
you're a team that works problem is if
you're in current research in
universities and places like
that and you don't get it right to begin
with somebody proves you wrong instead
of the way it used to be where you would
get feedback and go again and maybe
somebody else would then be interested
in your idea and following up on it now
you tend to get your funding yanked and
you get made fun of and you might not
get funding again I mean it's a very bad
scientific environment that we have at
the moment and that's really hard and
it's really hard to make science go
forward so you have a lot of people
unfortunately not I think because they
want to but because the incentive system
is don't admit you made a mistake don't
you know hang on to your ideas because
that's the only way you're going to hang
on to your funding and keep working and
that's a very bad situation to be in
because reality is reality right
is so thinking along those lines we
heard an awful lot of it's the science
right this is the science or as fouchi
would I would say that that is the
antithesis of the science because the
science is always open it's always
looking it's always improving it's
always trying to
find where am I not right you know we're
testing and and and as soon as you stop
and say this is it this is the science
then when you get new information you're
not going to look at it because I am the
science and therefore I'm not going to
look at somebody you know new
information that's coming in and that
dangerous
um the theory well science has to be
nimble open-minded and ready to change
in the face of counter
examples and it must change in the face
of counter examples because somewhere
there's a misunderstanding a
misconception and if you proceed with
that
misconception bad things will happen now
do you have to have it all right before
you act on it no because that's part of
how you're learning right but you have
to keep that open mind you have to keep
looking all right so an emergency comes
up you act on what you have but you keep
taking in new data you keep adjust in
your theory you can't stop at any point
you can't you have to keep going you
have to have an open mind as the person
before has kept talking about it's
critical especially in an emergency
situation where there's so much we don't
know you have to keep that open mind the
whole
time and when you hear people talking
about the
science the science in capital letters
you need to start looking at what are
they avoid
voiding what's in it for them is the
decision they're making actually based
on science or is it based on politics or
money are there counter examples with
other scientists that come up with are
they looking at them refining their
Theory or are they holding on to their
Theory without considering they may be
an error again why Pride politics power
money as Representatives who need to
make the best decisions for our
constituents it's important to ask these
questions it's important to consider
conflicting points of view it's
important to look for those counter
examples it's important to seek out
other scientists points of view don't
rely on publicized mainstream media to
find those scientists do your due
diligence throughout the covid response
there was a plethora of information out
there just as we do with
bills if you don't understand the topic
seek out the people who do learn from
them educate yourself the number of
people goodness all through Co who I
know I met with and various other people
from my committee and other committees
met with we had the doctors we had the
scientists we had the the guy who came
in and spoke in the beginning from
industry he came into our committee and
spent a good bit of time explaining to
us how you mitigate um whatever is going
on you know whether it's a biological
leak a radioactive leak or whatever he
explained how it's done
so I mean that's there's a whole lot we
can't know everything we can't but if
we're faced with something we at least
and the other thing to ask when
somebody's telling you do this or this
is the right thing to do or this is what
we should do ask what's in it for
them and it may be all that's in it for
them is what's best for their
constituents or for the kids as the
person before us but sometimes it's more
than that or outside of that and
sometimes what they're suggesting is
actually counterproductive to what's
best for the citizens or what's best for
the kids and so by asking that it helps
you understand where they're coming from
and
maybe if there's something else that you
at we had Frontline doctors who actually
dealt with patients sick covid patients
and they were reporting things which
what worked and what didn't work and
what happened to those doctors they were
denied access to hospitals some of them
lost their licenses because what they
were saying worked it
worked but it didn't follow the status
that shouldn't we have tried the pro
protocols those doctors were finding
successful rather than taking away their
ability to practice and to help patients
we allowed as the previous speaker said
way too much of our covid response to
become political and there was no reason
for it I mean if we have and that's on
both sides I'm not pointing fingers at
any one party or other it became very
political and when you're faced with
something when you're trying to solve
problems and protect people that's the
last thing you want is for politics to
it one of the ones that stands out to me
as being very
political at one point president Trump
was fighting covid and he made a comment
about hydroxy chloroquin showing some
potential and needing to research it
further but rather than doing so man and
I could not believe the reaction he says
this might work you would think this
might work means we're were going to
look at it no that became like the evil
the hydroxy chloroquin you couldn't get
it you couldn't use it
[Music]
um and we didn't even look to see what
other countries were doing because there
were countries for which it was a great
prophylactic who did not get covid or
had very low incidence of Co
because they were taking hydroxy
chloroquin for malaria or for you know
various other things we didn't even look
at that because it became a
political thing when there was no reason
for that you know it's a medicine search
the medicine just because somebody you
don't like said it doesn't mean that
makes it
bad and unfortunately that's what we
saw um
they even went so far as to do a
study who were given hydroxy
chloroquin just before they died when
they were dying when there was no other
hope and then they were given more than
what was recorded as the safe dosage
when it had been studied you know you
always say up to this amount and no more
they were given more than
that and guess what they died but
instead of looking at it scientifically
and saying well what can we learn from
that can we learn what you know is it
too late to give it do you have to give
it earlier we couldn't even do that
because we gave more than the
recommended dose so they could even have
you know the treatment could have worked
we have no way of knowing because we
gave them a lethal
dose you know and even the Lancet which
had published that withdrew it because
they said it was such a bad study and
yet we heard about it over and over and
over and over and over you know these
things go out into the Press somebody
misstates something somebody makes
something up
sometimes um and it just has a life of
its own and you can show what was wrong
with it but that doesn't that doesn't
take on the life that the initial
misstatement
does if that was really
science we would have backed it up we
would have said okay it doesn't work at
that what if we give it a week earlier
you know what if we give what if we work
on the proper dosing you would have
followed it up instead of just
developing
this faulty study and then that's it we
proved you can't use it we proved it's
no good and end of statement let's go on
and
science and then you have to ask
why now by then they knew they were
working on vaccines I mean they started
working on vaccines very early on but
they also knew if they were going to
bring this vaccine out whatever vaccines
they brought
out it was probably going to have to be
under emergency youth Au use
authorization
um but to do that you can't have any
treatment that
works so if you have a treatment that
works you can't bring out that
vaccine so is that why they did it they
had to prove there was you know things
that looked like they were going to work
ior mechon was another one
there were countries all over who were
using Ivermectin very successfully there
were doctors who were using iorc very
successfully Frontline
doctors some of them lost their licenses
for doing so even though it was approved
for any use right it was determined to
be completely safe and doctors had been
using it for other
uses for a long time now we can't have
that
why was that was that science was that
politics was that money was that
power we got to look at that why did we
make those decisions why did we do
that it doesn't make any sense I mean in
India they couldn't vaccinate everybody
they didn't have they didn't have the V
you know in the beginning when it came
out so they sent these people into the
poor to reach places with these Med
packs and in them it had things like
vitamin C vitamin D Ivor mecon you know
some of the things that have been found
to
work and the people who were going in
there were taking them they found that
those people did not get
covid and that was you could look at
that as a really big liveaction
study um because other regions of India
were being highly
infected but where they used that and
that was just supposed to be a stop Gap
until they could get the vaccines there
but it
worked and yet we said you can't do that
so why why what is the science and what
is the not science what is behind the
making then there was the question of
mass s which was brought up by again our
previous speaker prior to June 12th
2020 many experts including fouchy and
the who spoke about the essential
uselessness of maske wearing in relation
to a virus like this an Airborne
virus according to a report by the BBC's
Deb Cohen the who changed their experts
finding on the essential uselessness of
masks in June under heavy political
politics by March 2022 the vast majority
of school buildings Nationwide were shut
down at their Peak the closures affected
at least 55.1 million students in
124,000 US public and private schools
reported education week in order to slow
the spread of the Corona virus governors
in 48 states either ordered or
recommended that schools remain closed
through the end of the 2019 2020
June parents were quite understanding at
this point schools were dealing with
high levels of uncertainty danger and
frequently shifting expert guidance
however they fully expected schools to
figure out how to reopen by the Fall
and as we heard in one of our first
hearings from the industry expert who
came to speak to us what they could have
done to reopen they got the money they
could have used it to put those filters
in that kill the virus even this even
the schools like Al in my town who are
too old we don't have an HVAC
system we have radiator units you
know we could have put filters in in
there we had the money too I mean that
came from the federal government so
there was no reason following the
science for any of the schools to have
stayed closed in the fall they had the
money they had the time and the knoow
there in June Randy wein Garten
president of the American Federation of
teachers told Fox News that in order to
reopen safely schools would need more
resources we need the money for PPE we
Garten said we need the money for extra
teachers we need the money for extra
cleaning and extra buses the federal
government responded with the cares act
including $ 13.2 billion in emergency
funding for schools across the country
to use for their core functions as well
as for coordination of preparedness and
response to the co V Corona virus
emergency technology acquisition Mental
Health services and activities related
to Summer learning nonetheless most
schools only offered online
instruction a national survey conducted
by Common Sense Media in August found
that 59% of teens reported that they
believed online learning is worse than
in-person learning whereas only 19%
reported the opposite some teens being
teens disliked remote learning so much
that they figured out how to take a
screenshot of them elv looking
engaged and posting it so they could
leave the virtual room and go do what
to of the public schools that did reopen
for in-person instruction most impose
Mass mandates and social
distancing but many of the schools which
at first reopened then closed again
parents started showing up at school
board meetings demanding that schools
reopen one might say that the parents
demands were
unreasonable except private schools were
reopening safely more than eight out of
10 private schools associated with the
National Association of Independent
Schools reopened in the fall of 2020
with full or partial imperson
instruction nationally by mid October
about 60% of individual private schools
were fully in person while just 5% were
just were remote only meanwhile more
than nine out of 10 Catholic schools
schools reopened for in-person
instruction and I'm not sure exactly
what the percentage was in New Hampshire
but what I do know that it didn't take
long for every single private school in
the state to be
full because the parents whose schools
were not open they just took their kids
and enrolled them in private schools or
Catholic schools
whatever um and there was not a place
for a single other
child um a number of the schools were
doing what they could to expand to take
in these extra kids so again I have to
ask is that science or is that politics
or what is that that public schools
aren't open and private schools are and
private schools we didn't hear about any
great epidemics of covid there was no
higher incidents than there was in the
general
public the long-term closing of schools
and the harm to Children academically
socially and emotionally was a decision
based not on health but I would say on
politics thanks to teachers
unions Stanford University did a study
which found that public schools in areas
with stronger teachers unions were
substantially less likely to reopen in
person even after controlling for
differences in local demographics school
districts and states that required Union
memberships union membership ship were
25% less likely to plan to reopen with
full-time in-person instruction than
school districts and right to work
states the relationship between
unionization and reopening decisions
remains substantively and statistically
significant even after controlling for
schools district size coronav virus
deaths and local infection
rates study published by Brown
University's annenburg Institute
concluded contrary to to the
conventional understanding of school
districts as localized and nonpartisan
actors we find evidence that politics
far more than science shaped School
District
decision-making Mass partisanship and
teacher Union strength best explain how
School boards approached
reopening a study by researchers at
Michigan State University found that
when Governors left it up to districts
whether to have in-person
education the decisions were more tied
to local po iCal partisanship and Union
severity in New Hampshire the
commissioner of Education was working
diligently to help schools reopen you
remember when he came and talked to us
and he gave us that whole outline of all
the the notices sent out from them and
and any school you know they were happy
to go and help them
reopen but all too many refused used to
do so we were told that they were just
following the science but to understand
why the schools really closed down we
need to follow the political science
unions represent the interests of their
members that means the teachers unions
represent the teachers not the students
or their families it was in the interest
of students and it was in the interest
of students and their families for
schools to reopen but the unions
believed it was in the interests of
their members to keep schools closed and
to use the prospect of reopening as a
bargaining chip under the pretext of
safety to extract concessions that were
entirely unrelated to covid
safety on July 24th 2020 Randy we Garten
declared let's stop the debate about
whether safety matters and start rolling
up our sleeves so we can get the
resources to meet the needs of the
students whether we're teaching remotely
or in person unions declared that they
couldn't reopen because the federal
government must provide schools with the
resources we need to reopen in a
reasonable manner it soon became clear
that the money in politics not science
were in play some of the demands made by
some teachers unions included get this a
federal bailout socialized medicine
defunding of the police tax hikes a
moratorium on new Charter schools or
voucher programs police free schools
cancelling rents and mortgages a
moratorium on evictions foreclosures and
taxing billionaires and Wall Street I'm
not sure what that had to do with
science or reopening schools safely but
this was going on across our country and
it did affect the teachers unions in New
Hampshire they might not have been
petitioning but they were listening
more and more research is showing that
reopening schools were not overly
endanger students and staff Lance Zumi
senior director of the center for
education at the Pacific Research
Institute told the Los Angeles Times in
October 2020 schools are not super
spreaders and school infection rates are
low even in places with high Community
rates meanwhile it was already becoming
clear that learning loss was happening
and this is in October
of
2020 in December 2020 a McKenzie report
warned of the high cost of this
prolonged period of remote learning from
rising rates of depression and anxiety
to the loss of student learning the
research showed that the cumulative
learning loss could be substantial
especially in mathematics with students
on average likely to lose 5 to n months
of learning by the end of this school
year that would be June of
21 in spite of this evident learning
loss and parental pressure on public
officials to reopen schools unions did
everything possible to keep schools
closed despite all the evidence that
opening schools was safe unions held
protests against reopening they
displayed mock gravestones makeshift
coffins and their own early obituaries
others used faked body bags signs with
things such as I can't teach from the
grave yeah two weeks to slow the spread
generation the unions also work behind
the scenes to influence the federal
agencies that school districts relied
upon to interpret the science regarding
covid in early 2021 the CDC was about to
issue new guidance for
reopening doc doents obtained via foyer
request by Americans for public trust
revealed that the major teachers unions
heavily Lobby the CDC to influence that
guidance emails acquire
requ acquired by the New York Post
revealed that CDC reopening guidance
used the language suggested to them by
Randy weart aft and in some cases
practically word for
word on the same day that the CDC
released its reopening guidelines the
AFT issued a press release praising the
CDC for producing a rigorous road map
based on science that our members can
use to fight for a safe reopening they
praise the guidelines for including
compulsory masking six feet of physical
distancing handwashing cleaning and
ventilation diagnostic testing and
contact tracing as well as vaccine
priority for teachers and School staff
in addition the AFT thanked the Biden
Administration for its $ 1.9 trillion
American Rescue plan and for creating a
culture of trust and collaboration with
the union and I did not write down but a
later amount was more money that would
then was spent on completely rebuilding
the um country's re rebuilt after the
war after World War II it was a huge
amount of money that was given to the
schools
so that all sounds good right what's
wrong with that except we know that the
science had already shown that maths
don't work for airborne viruses partly
as was explained to us but partly as was
you know at from the industry experts
but partly as was explained to us by Dr
fouchy and the who in the very
beginning so it's not like oh we just
made that up and if you want to look at
who might know whether or not it works
look on the sides of the boxes it says
do not use for children under 12 years
of age it says does not work to prevent
covid transmission does not work to
prevent catching covid it says right on
the box with the masks so you know
somewhere in there is the science and
somewhere in there is something that's
not science and if the very people who
are developing and making the MTH say
this doesn't work for what you're
wanting to use it for I would hope those
them and in addition we now know from a
study done by environmental and water
chemistry for human health group that
masks not only don't stop covid but they
may release up to
5,390 microplastic particles in a
24-hour period and surgical mask in
particular May release approximately
3,152 microfibers in less than one
pasas so we have made people for one to
two years wear these
masks that have higher levels of pest
than we've been trying to outlaw in the
in
addition talk about science the six-
foot distancing was made up by a school
girl for her science fair
project that's where that came from but
her dad was a
modeler and her dad took that and back
when Bush was trying to come up with
what are our national emergency
plans um the guy presented it and the
immunologists and the doctors were there
who said that's not going to work but
she said masking in six foot distance
that was her theory for a science fair
project her dad you know took it the
experts all said you're crazy that's not
going to work why are you even listening
to that but the dad what I say was a
modeler he had snazzy presentations and
the government took it and listened to
him instead of the experts so there's
science for
you
[Music]
not
um
and contract tasing one of the other
things that was used to shut down whole
classrooms at a time for like two weeks
at a time so one kid had been in contact
with somebody someplace who might have
had covid and now his whole classroom
and anybody he's been in contact with
weeks and what was the CDC planning on
saying before the teachers unions got
hold of
instruction that was their plan that was
what they were going to
say in a text message exchange later
revealed by a foyer request by the fair
a county parents Association weine
Garten raised concerns about this
language with the CDC director wilinsky
the cdc's final language was
significantly wimped changing the word
can to have options to so that the
guidelines read all schools have the
option to provide in-person
instruction which is not the same as all
schools can do
this other important guidance was also
arranged to be altered by the AF there's
a whole list of them you can go and read
it so the guidance which wrought such
Havoc with our children's
education ultimately setting them back
at least two years rather than being
based on science was based on Union
political
machinations the very unions dealing
with teaching and education were
responsible for the anti-education which
took took place once again politics
rather than
science and you say 2 years well you
know in two years they'll make up for it
no problem except that people's brains
develop in a sort of a logical
chronological order and at various times
they're more or less receptive to
learning certain
things and so yeah you miss a week you
miss a month but you missed two years
you may well have missed that
whole time period where the brain is
ready to receive certain things all
those kids who had trouble
speaking they're learning how to talk
they're learning what it's all about now
you have a askk and you can't hear and
you can't see what anybody's doing with
going Earth how are you supposed to know
how to make those words how are you even
supposed to hear what those words
are we had a bill on something
completely different but having to do
education and somebody from the special
um administrators organization was in
talking to us and she was talking about
how they couldn't
get
um
sufficient people to come into all the
schools to teach what the kids needed
and somebody might have even been a rep
beler over there asked why are there so
many you know why is there such a
greater need than normal and her
covid I'm hoping she'll come and and be
able to talk to you in sometime in the
next few weeks because I went and talked
to her afterwards and I said Co why Co
and she said well math and school
closures the number of speech therapists
that are needed now to try to teach
those kids how to talk who spent two
years with masks and everybody around
them wearing
masks we don't have that many speech
therapists in the State trying to get
the services for these
kids they're not able to do
that um and the and the school closures
she said kids sat and watch The Boob
Tube you know for all that time you know
they they weren't
learning and as you saw what the some of
the teenagers were doing they weren't
even present they were doing whatever
they wanted to
do
um along with the anxiety the mental
difficulties Etc from having gone
through that it's it's rough and so I'm
hoping she said she would put together
talk to all the other um administrators
in the state and in her or in you know
in her organization and hopefully she'll
be able to come and tell you cuz she
said yes she has lots of data and she
will be happy to share the
Co I didn't want to quite go to the
vaccines
yet I wanted
to comment about the masks because the
divisive um my daughter-in-law's dad was
sick he was slowly
dying so everybody had to have masks her
kids who lived in the same
place could not see their grandparents
because if they didn't didn't wear their
mask they might kill their grandparents
if they touch the grandparents they
might kill their grandparents what a
horrible thing to do to a
kid they came to see me
outside 6 feet wasn't enough 16 feet
they had to stay away they didn't
understand why they couldn't come and
give me a
hug I was fine with it but I couldn't
wear a mask because I had um really bad
asthma at the time and putting the mask
on dropped my O2 noticeably anytime I go
to the doctor's office of course you
have to wear the mask and they take the
O2 and they'd look startled and
concerned and they'd say drop your mask
and I drop my mask and then they'd sigh
relief because my O2 would pop up okay
it's just the mask and I'd have to put
it back on again well I'm not running
around wearing a mask that's keeping my
O2 long enough that my nurse is
concerned
you know that was the last I ever saw my
grandkids cuz I didn't wear a
mask cuz it
couldn't it was a long time ago I used
to come all the
time I'm not unique I hear this story
over and over and
over families who never see each other
friends who never see each
other for something that didn't even
work
that we knew didn't even work and we
again this brings us to the
vaccines we've learned through the
testimony of Aaron Siri how science was
totally
ignored all of his evidence came from
the vaccine manufacturers and the FDA
and
CDC through what they had published on
their own and that which was acquired
through foyer
requests I'm not going to go over these
we had seven hours and an extra two
hours while they presented all of
that but I just want to remind
us that many signals were apparent long
before the testing was finished and
according to precedent and law the test
should have been stopped and the vaccine
declared unsafe at that
point instead in the middle of the tests
the experiments they change the
definitions and testing
criteria how scientific is that oh we're
getting signals that says this is not
safe this is dangerous in fact well
let's just change our criteria so it
where is that considered Prof proper
where is that considered proper
scientific
methodology besides failing their own
tests which the FDA knew but okay the
vaccines anyway they totally redefine
them a true vaccine is understood to
keep the vaccinated individual from
getting the disease as well as stopping
the transmission of the disease that's
how vaccine was
always um defined but they had to change
that because they realized these
vaccines didn't do
that people still get vaccinated and
still get covid people still get
vaccinated and spread
covid so the whole idea of having
vaccine mandates mandating that somebody
take something into their body which
they don't want or don't consider to be
them because somehow that's going to
stop covid except we know it wasn't
going to so why again where's the
science and what were those decisions
on only the drug companies in their
early public reports admitted they
didn't seem to be the case and in fact
they had too little information to
determine its effic
and yet we were repeatedly told that the
vaccine was safe and
effective we we are not clear of blame
here five minutes of research would have
given us that some people did that five
minutes of research and they put it out
because it was in the original posts
posted by those vaccine companies and
yet we allowed those mandates to take
knowing or could have been knowing if we
had bo even bothered to
look that the manand that the vaccines
weren't going to do what we were
expecting them to do and so there was no
reason to mandate them it should have
been an individual decision because we
anybody if we were truly interested in
science rather than politics and money
we would have not mandated vaccines for
anyone especially children and pregnant
women you don't take chances or normally
you don't take chances with children and
pregnant women those are like hands
did in fact a study was done to
determine if the vaccine was safe for
pregnant women in their first
trimester the results looked very bad
bad the incidence of miscarriage after
the shot was given was many times higher
than normal I tried to go back and look
up those numbers I read that study at
the time it was huge but of course it
disappeared as so much
information at the time so many studies
disappeared well that one was
disappeared as
well well they couldn't bring out that
and say oh it's really not safe you're
way more likely to have a miscarriage so
what did they do they added a huge
number of third trimester pregnant
women to bring down that number so they
could say only the incidence is only a
little higher and there was a little
asterisk on the study that said that's
what they did in tiny print you had to
read it but it was
there it's not how you do a study that's
the
publicly then they publicly stated that
the vaccines were safe and effective
even for pregnant women in their first
trimester even though they knew that
wasn't true even though their studies
showed what a huge increase it was for
miscarriages how many babies died
because we followed the politics and
money rather than the
science how many moms are dealing with
guilt of having listened to the lies and
having killed their much desired
babies I personally know of one a nurse
at conquered hospital she and her
husband desperately wanted a child but
she was a healthc care worker and was
thus mandated to get the
shot remember when we passed that bill
that said that if you take State money
you can't mandate the
workers since she was in her first
trimester she asked her doctor if it
would be safe he regurgitated the S
standard the vaccines are safe and
effective and that she should get this
shot to prevent the baby from getting
sick in case she were to catch
thereafter but we now know even if she
had successfully delivered the baby
because she'd been vaccinated her milk
would cause the bifid of bacteria in her
baby's gut to die
off bifido bacteria is an important part
of our immune system newborns are
supposed to have a ton of bifido
bacteria 90% of the microbiome of babies
if bifido
bacteria one of the common findings in
autistic children is the loss of bifido
bacteria how many sickly or autistic
children will we now have because we
followed the politics and money rather
science I went and talked with
those healthcare
workers who were protesting outside of
conquered hospital because in not too
many weeks that in they were going to
have to be vaccinated or lose their jobs
about 20% of the workers at conser
hospital and I asked them now let me let
me get this straight you guys worked
through covid you didn't mind coming in
every day risking getting covid and a
number of them said and we
did and doing your job in that horrible
time and
now you just have to get a vaccine or
you lose your your job and you're not
willing to get the vaccine you were
willing to work during covid but you're
not willing to work you're not willing
to get the vaccine you're willing to
lose your job what have you
seen why did you make that
started the woman who got her vaccine
and her body became quickly filled with
blood clots she was out of work for a
long
time the woman whose doctor when she had
gone to get her flu vaccine the year
before she had had a mild reaction and
the doctor had
said you should probably never get any
other vaccines because I think you've
become allergic to them and it could be
very
dangerous but she had children
and no
husband and she needed to support those
children and she went to her doctor well
what do you think well you know you
could have a serious allergic reaction
well can you write me a medical
exemption no I can't do that because if
I did that I would lose my
job so she got vaccinated because she
didn't want to lose her job because she
didn't know how she was going to support
her
kids she was within 7 Seconds of being
brain dead before they managed to get
tracheotomy and the list went
on and that's why they weren't willing
to take those risks nor should they have
had
to and I remember how ugly it was then I
remember some woman a nurse three young
and she Saidi don't believe in this I
don't want to do this Etc and they said
all right you don't do it you're
fired and she got the vaccine and I
remember people on the Press were
crowing about it and laughing she had no
principles she just needed to be
bought no she needed to take care of her
children she had principles that
unfortunately she had to give up in
order to to make sure her children could
eat and had a place to live and yet
her I don't want to live through that
again I can remember sitting at an ice
cream stand with my friend and her kids
we'd gone camping we stopped for ice
cream we're sitting at the picnic table
and we're talking about some of the
things that we'd recently learned
studies that we'd recently read lady in
the other table oh this is terrible and
she comes over and starts chastising us
and berating us and we should get
vaccinated and you know that's all
balone and we're not scientists how can
we study that how can we possibly
understand that she's a scientist well
coming to find out she had fewer
qualifications than either one of us did
to understand what those studies were
she knew nothing she didn't know who we
were she just came and started Bering us
for not getting vaccinated and finally I
looked at her and I said lady you know
nothing about me if I took that vaccine
I'd be dead most
likely I have so many um autoimmune
issues that is there there's no way I
should take that vaccine but you didn't
know that she kind of vaguely apologized
vaguely but then made sure to shake her
finger at us and still tell us we
shouldn't talk about those
things that's the society we were living
ugly we couldn't know about the lack of
efficacy of the vaccine nor the dangers
associated with it that's not that we
really couldn't but they were going to
make sure we
couldn't the government had social media
platforms censor the information
available
I had many entries on Facebook censored
for supposed
misinformation I would post actual
studies not commentaries made by
reputable and well-regarded hospitals
and they would be declared
misinformation and people couldn't read
them they'd be blanked out with that
misinformation across them I remember
one of them early on was doctors working
at the hospital and they said you know
we're killing people
because their lungs aren't filled with
liquid we're treating them as if their
lungs are filled with liquid what we're
finding is their lungs are filled with
blood clots and when we
use the ventilators we're actually
blowing out their
lungs and at the same time there was a
video by a nurse who was in tears
because she was trying to treat these
people and she was watching them be
killed before her eyes by doctors who
were blowing out their lungs now she
assumed they were just using too high of
pressure but if that study could have
been not misinformation maybe people
could have read that and said oh this is
inappropriate treatment and maybe a lot
of people's lives would have been saved
but no we couldn't have that
misinformation so they kept blowing out
people's
and the number of times I look back at
those studies later well I can't see
them but I remember what they were and I
I can go back to the Facebook page and I
can comment huh funny how this is now
accepted as TR you know fact but it was
misinformation at the time even though
it was a real scientific study with real
facts that's can't be misinformation
conclusions but what they saw is what
they saw right the test results are the
test
results but the government went to some
lengths to make sure we didn't know the
truth when too many people who had been
vaccinated began to get covid they
changed their testing
protocols initially they had set the
cycle thresholds to 40 CT even though
there was an apparent scientific
consensus regarding the
unreliability in favor of false
positives of all PCR tests operated
Beyond 30 to 33
CT but when they noticed too many
vaccinated getting covid they adjusted
it to 28 CT for the purposes of
calculating the number of cases suddenly
appearing in the cohort of the
vaccinated at the end of 2021 our
Department of Health and Human Services
was strongly advertising that the vast
majority of people coming down with
covid were the
unvaccinated only I happen to have a
large straddle pulmonary embolism at
about that time and I was in the
hospital three three different nurses
three different departments three
different floors of the hospital when
they found out that I was um State Rep
they made sure to tell me that most of
the people that they were seeing with
vaccinated not the
unvaccinated in spite of what our
Department of Health and Human Services
was advertising and you could see them
on all the TVs and the banners flowing
across Etc
so I mentioned that to another rep and
she called the department and said so I
see you're advertising that the
um that the majority of people who are
getting covid right now are the
unvaccinated oh yeah can you give me the
numbers uh well we have no way of
tracking that we really
can't figure you know well how can you
say that the majority of people is one
it I would love to ask the department
that so my question is what was in it
what was in it for him to completely
make up the
science that most of the people were
unvaccinated when he couldn't even you
know he couldn't track those numbers at
why we keep learning more and more
things about what was known and what was
not known both from whistleblowers and
foyer
requests why did people ignore science
at the expense of people's lives and
livelihoods I believe that is a question
we need to answer if we're going to not
make the same mistakes
again we need to learn to look past the
politics the money the power to see the
beauty of the truth we need to school
ourselves in looking at multiple points
of view in realizing that there if there
are multiple path multiple points of
view then perhaps our idea Theory
we need open Pathways of communication
which allow us to gather as much diverse
information and points of view as
possible we need to be open to these
contrary ideas regardless of which party
they come from no one has a monopoly on
science we need to be sure to follow
money so I'm open for questions or
comments
representative
Merchant thank you madam chair and also
thank you for taking the question
represent leas first and foremost I hope
you have a wonderful time in yor thank
you so much seven weeks sounds a great
time to get out of here um also my
condolences to you and your
grandchildren um that's a very sad story
to hear um I've also heard from other
grandparents having something comparable
to it it
it tore P families apart politically um
so I reach out to you with a lot of
empathy thank you very much I think you
testimony speaks to what I consider to
be the three PS you throw fourth one
there as well um it comes down to his
profits power and
politics and fundamentally where science
lies in that I'm not sure but also the
fourth p is paranoia there's a
tremendous amount of fear of the unknown
and I I think you're hitting upon the
issue of how do we deal with the
psychology not so much the science but
the science of people psychology of
people how they respond to the unknown
and the fear is something maybe we
should be thinking about embedding into
anything going forward both at the state
and National level but I think
fundamentally when you get in we as a
person as a society get into something
we don't understand fear takes over and
when fear takes over not just politics
it's the issue of how do we deal and how
do we help people get through that fear
so thank you for Testimony this morning
I think it's insightful and hope you
have a wonderful time in your thank you
and to follow up on what you just
said
um we should look at what we did to
expand fear and what we could do to
decrease fear because certainly telling
kids that if they didn't wear masks
they'd kill their grandparents parents I
think that kind of expanded fear and not
decreased it and that is something that
was being said to young children which
is unfortunate but yeah and we talked a
little bit about that in our very first
or second
meeting with um Homeland Security PE you
know is how how could we have addressed
the situation to begin with and how in
the future when we have unknown how can
we address the situation I think that's
a great thing to look
at I concur I would say unfortunately we
got into the political part of it which
only drove the fear right it became
divisive and unfortunately we didn't
find ways to reach across the aisle
collectively and talk about how we can
help people address the fear issue and
build some trust within the institutions
for them to rely upon instead we didn't
do that as a society both at the state
absolutely represent vble yeah I just
want to Echo what uh representative uh
Merchant said I had a situation where my
mother was in a nursing home and I you
know I couldn't see her for I don't even
you she was
95 it was it was a anyway it was very
difficult time so I would say um
what you're talking about is the point
of this committee I think that our
country and the world was Ill prepared
to deal with a pandemic and I'm really
hoping that by looking at how we reacted
to it we're going to do a lot better
next time and I think that the lack of
preparedness and the lack of knowledge
and the
scrambling um created a vacuum where
fear and politics could pour in and and
you know we just didn't have the
resources and the Kno how to react
properly I mean I'm I really I'm I'm
glad for instance that the governor had
this after Action Report done because
they pointed out things and we should be
able to do better next time and and I
think truly understand that pandemics
like this can happen
like in a matter of a week or two I mean
it spreads like crazy and maybe do
less panicky
you I would like to thank you
um for being here and telling your story
and how difficult uh life got for
you um I know many people that have got
said I hear the stories with the
mandates with vaccines I hear the
stories with kids being
vaccinated or
injected with a with something without
parental
consent and yet there's no recourse for
those parents and
done I think my personal opinion is that
we need to put something in place to
penalize those people that are not doing
their due diligence and listening to
parents and understanding that just
because they think and
they're they're based on whatever
they're hearing they want every one to
be injected with a vaccine or a flu that
there has to be consequences for their
actions because if we don't have
consequences for our
listen and we see the consequences of
what happened with the fear in this
country and with people I know I had
someone come up and scream scream at me
in my
face and I was following the social
here
we no matter what it is that comes down
the pike and I think you pointed out
represent Merchant represent evil
discuss it is that we need to be
open-minded and we need to react in a
positive and not a negative thing we
heard in testimony here from one of the
Commissioners said that one of the
things that they did is they set a
course and they didn't vear from
it which means that was it no matter
what happened they were staying on
track and to
me when new information comes in you
have to
me data is changing all the time and the
fact that people are posting
things that went against the narrative
and I'm going to just say this as a
narrative um from what was popular
because that they it was taken down and
considered
disinformation if we can bring all
people to the table even those you
disagree
with I
find that through opposing views you get
to the the actual the
truth because nobody is right all the
time and if we bring we all are looking
through a lens of bias and if we take
that and get down to the root and we can
all understand where everyone's coming
from and then why this person is saying
that this is working why this person is
saying that is
done
and I truly believe that the people that
suffered most under this pandemic are
the
children the mental health issues we're
going to see for decades to
Untold because we put such fear in them
and those young minds cannot process
it I see adults still today fearful
themselves it is amazing what leaders
people and I think we need to learn that
leaders in in our state and anywhere no
matter where you are whether it's the
teachers or you know the
CEO we have responsibilities to
encourage people to be the best of
themselves and how do we
diminish instilling fear in
function and I think this is where the
psychology of all of this comes into and
we have to be able to
discern the money
politics
and we like I said we all come from
different biases but it is our children
that has suffered the most I was just at
a conference and one of the topics that
was brought up um the gentleman it was
in looking at lenses and saying you're
going to have to convince me uh that I
need to take the covid vaccine
you should have heard the room they were
like you're going to bring up that topic
and so we had to get into groups and how
to convince this person why they should
take the
vaccine it was very difficult for a lot
of people to be having that
discussion but they couldn't get past
the narrative that we've been told at
the
top some people said understood because
they had someone that passed away other
people had you know we all come from
different lenses but to say something is
safe and effective when other people
have experienced deaths because of that
or the
miscarriages or the health issues that
over and I really thank you for bringing
all of that up in your in your testimony
today and I think it's important that
this committee really look at how we can
respond and I think the honorable Betty
gay when she was here had some really
good insight into collaborating with all
different people going forward to come
together and I really think that as a
state we did we did well but I think we
can do better
vacation um not seeing anyone else in
the room um I guess I'm going to put
this question to the group um we can
call it a
day okay so I think we'll call it a day
today I think at some point we should
come back to discuss the uh Homeland
Security
report um represent
beler thank you I I just wanted to speak
on that real quick because I'm aware
that it was already um read into the
record earlier this um uh report the
after Action Report however there's a
provision early in this report and I I
saw as browsing through that I think
we're going to need to uh get some um
advice and Counsel on to figure this out
because despite the fact that I've been
I've I've already pred this whole report
and it seems perfectly fine to me that
it should be public knowledge however
there is a tight there's a beginning
here this this is actually a classified
report and this is not for public
disclosure and internal use only and
there appears to be penalties attached
as far as I can tell within the law that
I've just looked up for this so I I
think we need to get a little bit of uh
guidance on why and whether this is
something that we need a non-public
session a public session I'd certainly
like to discuss it publicly because
there's certainly things in here that I
think could be useful um but there it
is thank you for bringing that to our
attention and representative
evil I did share it with you but it was
associated with a a press release by the
governor um so they
I don't disagree with you that was a I
mean I read that first thing and I'm
like I don't I don't understand what's
going on here but um I just wanted to
say that it come it did come through the
governor's office so apparently at least
they made some kind of the determination
that it was um that it was public
there's um I mean since I had obtained
it originally there's a contact name
there and if some I don't mind giving
that person in a call and just making
sure what the uh circumstances are if
the committee would like me to do that I
okay so yes and and they told us that it
was going to be available to us when
they came in here so it wasn't like this
is a big surprise to anyone that is
watching so um I I read sorry I read
that and I thought well maybe they meant
all the backup information or something
and not the report itself but I I agree
with representative but belter that was
written in
a I don't know yeah disarming way I
would say represent Merchant thank you
madam chair there's also something I'd
like to submit to the committee um once
I get access to my uh
internet there's something called the
psychology of pandemics written by
stepen Tyler from Canada dealing with
this old issue and trying to frame in
such way I think would be helpful for
the community to look at and review but
I think also for the report itself and
talking about how do we deal with
pandemics going forward dealing with
psychology of the pandemics versus
looking at it from a science point of
view I think it's important we include
that I'll send it to you right now okay
thank you Ste Taylor tayor Taylor Sorry
Taylor oh
yeah I'm I'm thinking Department of uh
commissioner from the Department of
Agriculture it's it's sort of a it's um
it's a short article basically but it
does cover some of the key points we're
trying to make as far as psychology it
deals with um how Society deals with
pandemics and the fear that goes along
with it thank you for sharing that with
us appreciate
it uh any anybody else have any other
comments I am not going to schedule a
meeting for next week if that's okay
with everybody
um so probably the Friday after that um
which would be the 20th I guess um
okay all right so thank you
everyone uh good luck on
Tuesday for all of those that are
running and uh have a great weekend
adjourned